the reason
the
johnny depp
versus
amber heard
trial is
taking so
long it's because
johnny depp
really takes his time
before
[Music]
answering
a question
you put that trial one and a half speed
and it sounds like they're talking
normally
no that's not the reason why the reason
why is because there's so much evidence
and testimony against him ted she pooped
she's going to reclaim her her victory
one test
four weeks of everything against her
like nope come on one
one testimony all i need boys forget
everything
as much as i've been following this my
buddy george
over at g01 films jason momoa reacts to
the johnny depp versus amber heard trial
dub this
is gonna be badass
let's do it
[Music]
she will hit the wall hard
four exclamation points
objection compound oh that's a nice
conjunction
and this wasn't the first time that you
talked about amber hitting the wall hard
let's pull up exhibit 213 please
sir
she's not going to be on for two days
and then he
showed me a photograph
there's a photograph of the bed
our bed
um
and on
my side of the bed
[Laughter]
it's ever turd
subscribe i'm gonna punch you
subscribe for me hey let's watch more of
this case
because
like this in the chair
looking at her first bottle went
what she's throwing bottles across the
room
[Laughter]
good detail
everywhere
i felt heat and i felt
uh as if something were dripping down my
hand johnny it was the liquor
realized that the
the tip of my finger yeah
had been
severed um
okay
this just got serious oh my god
oh my god nice
looking directly boy johnny depp don't
say that's bone
sticking out
yeah i bet those things were stinging
smelly
oh my god
man now the only thing i think of when i
see her is hashtag amber turd yup
oh my god
and i bet he sounds like that when he's
dropping an amber turd
well a lot of speculation has arisen
that indeed jason momoa
does support johnny depp because
this isn't brought up in the trial
obviously why would it be however i
think uh he followed him on social media
did i read that correctly
objection
hearsay hearsay compounded you're saying
but that's exactly what you just did
every heart was when amber's lawyer
asked a question to a witness and then
objected to his own question
[Music]
seconds later that's the funniest part
i don't know how else you would read
that it's bizarre that's amber hurts his
co-star his next biggest movie
aquaman reportedly she might only have
like 10 minutes of screen time in the
movie that's a significant amount of
green time for two and a half hours here
i mean ten minutes can feel like a lot
longer you know especially with somebody
whose presence looms over a movie like
it ever hurts is short they might as
well just dialogue her out in a way i
think i think they just have to say
something to his dialogue around the way
they've hand handled paul walker being
dead fast and furious yeah that's what
they should do with her show all of her
lines off screen go back and just use a
bunch of coverage so that you know
told me this or i'm on the water
magic conch shell
she's got so much to say hold on i'll
repeat it to you in a minute yeah i just
reshoot a couple scenes in front of the
green screen at james wan's house
put a water tank behind him yeah
that'd be fine you barely even notice
the difference barely
right now
george man this is uh this is hilarious
i think what you captured here is so
well because you always have that said
the specific type of voice you do for
these dubs but he's actually sounded
like
i love how in your dubs you often create
these sort of voices and characters that
are obviously based on the person and
the the content you're drawing from but
here yeah i think this felt the most
like i bet this is what it's like to
watch the real jesus
react to this trial and these outlandish
testimonies if he had that attitude
towards the trial yeah it would sound
just like this yeah i'm sure he takes it
seriously it has real conversations but
man i can i can only imagine you know
especially for someone like mamoa who
even took a stand for ray fisher as well
puts him in a tough position here i can
imagine he probably does really support
johnny depp i'm excited for 10 years
down the line when he can finally talk
about it yeah i'm sure there's something
in there or
don't talk about ezra
don't talk about it
and don't talk about it oh he could dude
as long as he stays cool he could
release some kind of weird tell-out
memoir that's like working with joss
whedon
or all these people
oh that was funny thank you thank you
george for putting this together
congrats on such a successful video
this was hilarious part three this was
genuinely hilarious that laugh
[Laughter]
yeah it just sounds like he's eating up
the drive yes that's what's so funny
about it like he's watching a
pay-per-view fight or something like
that
subscribe to gom man
thanks for being here guys